et nous y sommes allés il y a huit ans, je l'ai eue
beaucoup de difficultés dans ce
touche les gens à croire qu'un
manger sainement était vraiment ce
dites-moi si l'agriculture biologique
pourrait vraiment être un point qui
pourrait changer notre façon de voir ici
nourrir et améliorer la planète
[Musique]
Le
parler je suis André Maciel fondateur de
les portes du projet Inspired 5 et nous sommes
dans la ville essayant de faire les villes
plus vert avec des jardins urbains
plus d'aliments biologiques et rend le
des villes écologiques plus durables et
l'équilibre est souvent venu parce que je
Je crois que la nourriture telle qu'elle est
la production retardée aujourd'hui est
fait et même l'agriculture elle-même
conventionnel à la fin est d'être
investi est l'un des plus
polluants du monde
pas le meilleur pour les moments de
aujourd'hui et c'est vraiment dommage de voir
si vous avez la planète et les gens avec le
produits chimiques tels que les pesticides
organismes génétiquement modifiés les
transgéniques et donc j'ai toujours eu ça
mission de vouloir et un énorme goût pour
la nature avec les animaux pour faire le
installation sur le terrain, puis je suis allé dans un
très vieille maison où ma mère
est né et ma mère est décédée il y a 17 ans
retour avec qui je ne vais pas non plus
masque alimentaire comment en faire un
discours plus tard à la fin elle doit
se soucie beaucoup de la nourriture et
m'a fait réaliser que c'est important et
ça je vais trier une maison
restaurer sa maison est née et puis
Je pensais que j'avais déjà un jardin et le
de là je
J'étais ravi de la peinture et je voulais
faites une commande de mon art à vos côtés
mais est-ce que c'est un écosystème avec beaucoup de
biodiversité et naturellement pour poster
un cycle pour se rendre compte que les billes
m'a donné de la nourriture
que leur fumier alimentait le potager qui
la nourriture qui est jardin là pour moi
me nourrir et la conception des poulets
d'équipement que j'ai fait donner un
profitez vraiment de toutes les fonctionnalités
naturelles que j'avais et c'est alors que
le clic m'a même donné envie de plus
prenez-les vraiment de cette façon et le
des jardins urbains voulant
produits biologiques dans les espaces urbains et Diário da
école sans bureaux la difficulté
la plupart l'ont été pendant sept ans 6 ans
Je peux convaincre Oh ok non parce que mon
est-ce que c'était plus tôt
public d'avoir des clients d'avoir quelqu'un qui
mieux et je n'ai jamais regardé celui-ci
projet en tant qu'entreprise, j'ai toujours cherché
pour ce projet avec une mission Auto
réactif a déjà plus d'activisme aussi
mais faire le vôtre fonctionne beaucoup avec
conseil en ligne avec le groupe Jobs avec
la partie pratique de la création effective du
propres jardins et effectuer l'entretien
puis le processus commence avec le client
contactez-moi et dites que vous avez de l'espace avec
J'aimerais avoir un potager et puis nous
nous demandons des photos bientôt, faites-nous celles-là
mesures et surtout l'exposition
solaire après avoir eu ces certitudes et
ces conditions tout mon vide
que le client lui-même nous faisons de notre mieux
personnalisez votre potager à la taille de votre
il est temps je dis toujours un potager
que nous avons ce que nous voulons que ce soit
toujours la taille du temps que nous avons
puis demandez Quels sont les légumes
que vous utilisez le plus dans votre alimentation et
nous avons fini par présenter un budget
avec l'entretien sans moi la construction du
protection de jardin un conseil que j'essaie
le plus quand je crée un potager
créé par la personne elle-même avec le client
ou avec l'entreprise elle-même
l'école pour qu'ils puissent rester
vraiment avec ces outils et partir
autonome et autonome pour créer
votre propre nourriture
[Musique]
donc dans un rêve toujours un but est
créer une école pour les enfants parce que
Je pense vraiment que les enfants sont comme ça
la clé principale pour atteindre
donner une continuité à l'être humain ici
notre course quand j'étais enfant je voulais
être votre principal mais ne pas connaître le
personne d'abord égale à ceux qui
J'avais mais plutôt essayer de donner la liberté
les enfants se rapprochent de la nature et
apporter sa propre nature
sera un message aux plus petits pour les
plus âgés et ils ont tous travaillé
Écologie de la responsabilité sociale
l'interaction avec l'autre s'échange ensemble et est
c'est l'objectif de l'Aide Hortas
c'est ce que nous avons réalisé et